es importante manifestar que este este
número o la intensidad de este fenómeno
criminal que realizó el ejército
nacional lo que aunque todavía cometen
ya las organizaciones de derechos
humanos y las organizaciones de víctimas
lo veníamos anunciando desde el año 2008
siempre se nos trató de mentirosos se
nos trató de decir que era un acto de
saboteo de hablar mal del gobierno
nacional y de las fuerzas militares para
nosotros es importante que hoy una
entidad del estado como la jurisdicción
especial para la paz haya hecho este
reconocimiento de la intensidad y el
número de víctimas que generó el
ejército nacional en una serie de
asesinatos donde todas las unidades más
de 200 batallones en 31 departamentos
están vinculados todas las divisiones
del ejército y que es absolutamente
necesario que la jurisdicción especial
para la paz de un paso no solamente en
identificar este universo de víctimas
sino en no repetir los errores de la
fiscalía o lo que ya hizo la fiscalía en
materia de investigación sino que de
forma definitiva como lo preguntan las
madres de todos estos casos
quien dio la orden y se puede llegar a
sus responsabilidades es una situación
que es bien importante ahora y que
esperamos que la gente no haga y que
continúe una investigación que no que no
pueda llegar a esa a esa respuesta
germán y le pregunto qué responsabilidad
tiene el expresidente álvaro uribe y los
gobiernos posteriores
alvaro uribe velez no solamente era el
presidente juan manuel santos era el
ministro de defensa ellos conocían de
primera mano lo que venía ocurriendo con
el ejército nacional a ellos se les fue
avisando por parte de naciones unidas-
por parte de las organizaciones de
derechos humanos que pasaba en el
departamento de antioquia en la costa
carillo en los llanos orientales en el
sur occidente del país y ellos tienen
una responsabilidad que han querido
negar y es cómo fue que orientaron al
ejército nacional en que tuviera un
mensaje de ganar la guerra
nosotros tenemos casos donde
directamente la labor de inteligencia y
la presión que se ejerció sobre los
comandantes de las divisiones la hizo el
expresidente álvaro uribe vélez común y
caldas en el eje cafetero y donde
claramente él ordenaba y pedía que una
unidad que daba resultados es decir que
cometía este tipo de ejecuciones pasar a
departamentos donde se necesitaba
representar este tipo
germán gracias por su tiempo y por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 que tenga
usted un feliz resto